this used to be our F gravely a Royal
Air Force Base near Cambridge now it's a
farm and some wind turbines in the 1940s
aircraft would set off from here to
fight in Europe and they hug they'd be
able to safely land back here as well
the problem with that was the fog or
rather smog all the soot and air
pollution from domestic coal fires
combined with fog to make an incredibly
thick pea soup it's never seen in modern
Britain because we don't burn smoke
producing coal in every house anymore
but back then if that smog came in even
runway lights wouldn't get through it
and there were no modern instruments to
guide the air crews home no way to take
off no way to land have you solved that
by setting enormous amounts of petrol on
fire this incredible photo shows a
Lancaster bomber
taking off from just behind me more than
70 years ago it looks like a movie stunt
but this is how wartime airfields boiled
off fog fed of enormous lines of petrol
burners to heat up the air vaporize all
the liquid water droplets to make steam
which will rise out of the way and clear
the air the system was called Fido fog
intensive dispersal of there are
demonstrations films taken by the RAF on
clear days showing just how big and how
visible this was there's a report in the
war Illustrated published just after
Victory in Europe that says that the
glow from the fires was visible for
miles a lot a bit of smoke when we'd
start the system up but once it got hot
the air could be so clear that people on
the ground could see the stars the catch
was how expensive it was a small Fido
system burned 70,000 gallons of fuel an
hour one after it so that in one foggy
night over England all the Fido systems
in use would burn 20 million gallons of
fuel there's even a report that all the
extra heat pumped into the atmosphere
triggered a thunderstorm at the current
price of jet fuel as I record this
running a Fido system would cost about
$200,000 per hour per runway it was
never used in peacetime aircraft could
just not take off instead and wait for
the fog to clear or divert to another
Airport or they're trying to land but
for the war effort to let planes take
off the battle in any weather and to
save thousands of our food lives who
needed to land right now it was worth it